you never want to talk about someone
that's such a dear and close friend
Candace Cameron Bure is standing by Lori
Lachlan side during an appearance on The
Today Show Tuesday the fuller house star
was asked about her co-stars alleged
involvement in a college bribery scandal
you know it's too personal to us and yes
you never want to talk about someone
that's such a dear and close friend but
I think I've already said that we are
family and we stand by each other and
pray for each other and we'll always be
there for each other
Candace first broke her silence at the
Kids Choice Awards in March when puller
House one favorite funny TV show
together no matter what they stick
together through the hard times they
support each other they encourage one
another they pray for each other and
they stand by their side no matter how
tough it gets and a loving family that
sticks together also celebrates the
really good times and it's no surprise
Candace has unconditional love for her
TV aunt the two are longtime friends
before the Netflix reboots they shared
the screen on Full House from 1987 to
1995 everybody makes mistakes the no
parent is perfect
Lori was arrested for allegedly paying
$500,000 to guarantee her two daughters
Olivia Jade and Isabella rose admission
to the University of Southern California
as members of the crew team even though
neither was an athlete I want them to be
happy so I want to be supportive of
everything they want to do but I do want
them to have somewhat of a normal you
know finish out of high school college
experience maybe because I didn't have
that I would really want that for them
Lori is reportedly not expected to
return for the fifth and final season of
fuller house Netflix had no comment when
each he reached out about the report
a source recently told et that Lori's
daughter's 19 year old Olivia and 20
year old Bella are quote suffering in
their own ways from the fallout of their
parents decisions adding Bella and
Olivia have a very tight-knit group of
friends who have been there to support
them they've needed that support because
they're being attacked at every turn
[Music]